avec tout ce moment que nous sommes
vivant ainsi, il est vrai que le
livres que la série que celui que le
les films nous aident à passer ce temps
mais je recommanderais aussi le
les gens prennent du temps
pour
pour deux choses l'une pour faire de l'exercice
bouger s'emmêler à
être en bonne santé et fort à ce sujet
moment que nous vivons
tout autre ce qu'il a dit non de
des hommes en bonne santé dans un corps sain" et d'autre part
côté recommanderais aux gens très très très
prends sérieusement ton temps
réfléchir à ce qui est
il se passe que non seulement que tout n'est pas
divertissement qui vous divertit
très bien mais si nous pouvons avoir le
capacité à distiller quelque chose de bon à partir de tout
ça se passe tellement bien
Eh bien, nous aurons l'occasion de
devenir une société au moins une
peu mieux et je pense que nous serions
très inintelligent et non sinon
nous profitons
[Musique]
la maison de papier serait le plus
Je recommanderais car cet homme est là
cela vous divertira beaucoup parce que
les personnages avaient besoin d'un moment
étranger dans leur vie, ils avaient besoin de se mettre à
l'enfer vraiment leur vie
il y a un jeu je pense ce qu'ils ont
réalisé est qu'il est très amusant
voir et ça et ça vraiment alors continuer
tachant les téléspectateurs qui
nous espérons que les gens ne le verront pas
à la maison surtout dans ces
les circonstances peuvent divertir un
un peu de temps et peut échapper un peu à ça
verrouillage
[Musique]
je joue beaucoup beaucoup avec mes enfants
j'aime les gens qui ont des enfants
Je recommanderais particulièrement de prendre le temps de
sois avec eux le plus grand de tous les
le temps qu'ils peuvent et laissez-les
proposer des jeux et rendre un peu quoi
c'est à l'enfance avec eux que moi
cela semble être une chose très saine que je suis
devenir geek de l'ego je suis avec l'ego
chaque jour j'ai un petit garçon
je l'ai ici scrabble
J'aime beaucoup le dictionnaire PRI
parce que je trouve ça très drôle
ceci pour deviner ce qui est ce qui est
dessiner les autres bien les nouveaux
et vous pouvez aussi jouer en multi
conférences
bob marley et entièrement tout son
discographie
Je pense qu'il accompagne beaucoup et me donne
beaucoup de joie et aide à maintenir le
espoir de santé pour vivre dans la tête
johnny cash johnny presque tous
johnny cash me parait fantastique
cette fois
[Musique]
et nous en tirerons des leçons et cela nous apprend
que nous sommes plus forts beaucoup plus forts
qu'on imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
il fait un très gros effort
afin que nous puissions nous en sortir au plus vite
la partie qui nous touche est de rester dans
maison soyons responsables nous devenons uniques et
exclusivement pour ce qui est nécessaire
absolument essentiel a envoyé un
message vrai très fort
beaucoup d'encouragements et jusqu'à ce que sûr que
on s'en sort relativement vite
mais que tant qu'il faudra
soyons responsables et restons
à la maison et à quel point et maintenant le
univers au lieu d'aller comme ça
allons comme ça et maintenant important de savoir que
il y a des gens qui marchent à nos côtés
tout comme nous et que nous avons
sensibilisation de la communauté